i feel like we have been making
croissants forever
[Music]
hello i'm hannah hart welcome back to
edible history the show that takes your
palate on a trip to the past today we're
going to be exploring the history of the
croissant where did it come from why is
it here how soon can i eat one i love
croissants it's the perfect pastry
period but were croissants born perfect
to find out i'm talking to jim chavalier
author of the book august zhang and the
french croissant by the start of the
19th century the austrians had two
roles they really liked one was the
kaiser symbol and made from the same
dough they made a crescent-shaped
version of this which was the kipful so
then a croissant is
related to the kaiser rule it was wow
this is a trick you have this austrian
officer named august zang
he came to paris did not like the bread
and he said what they need is austrian
bread he opened this bakery on the rou
de la schedule and he began to sell
austrian specialties the french bakers
began to make the kip full but because
it was shaped like a crescent they just
said here this is a crescent and in
french crescent is quasi so you're
telling me that the croissants heritage
isn't
as french as i think there's a whole
range of austrian baking techniques
which have completely transformed french
baking from august zhang on
like a modern day august zhang jim's
brought me knowledge of an austrian
pastry i've never heard of before
however i want to make something
slightly different luckily jim's given
me a recipe for cuasanto bear by urban
dubois dating back 137 years the basic
ingredients for our croissants
are milk flour salt and butter now you
may have noticed there's no butter on
this table well that's because we're
gonna make it and making it looked a
little something like this
uh first things first you gotta get your
hands on one of these wow we'll be
making a pound and a half of butter
which is eight cups of heavy cream mmm
makes you want a cup of coffee and now
we churn
i feel like this should have been a
closed set fyi i'm gonna be doing this
for like the next 20 minutes
oh my god i think it's working okay
so it's now achieved
more of like a squishing feeling than a
sucking feeling my arms have achieved a
fatigue feeling let's take a look look
at that
i can't believe it is butter
next we have to separate the butter from
the buttermilk
okay this is heavier than i thought
oh
yeah
and butter
oh joy of choice okay so uh you know we
lost a little bit in the process but hey
nobody said cooking was clean this
technically we're baking what i'm doing
now is i'm squeezing out the last bits
of the buttermilk from the butter this
will improve the shelf life of our
butter and keep it from going bad
squeeze
we've got a pretty beautiful butterball
butterball there's a reason behind
everything
now let's unwrap our cheesecloth and see
our beautiful buttery creations
everything is sticking to my buttery
hands get that moisture out our fresh
butter
for you now that we're done with our
butter time to start making our dough
[Music]
so to make our dough we actually have to
make two doughs the first being a lemon
dough to make 11 bread duh you need
yeast they didn't even put it in the
ingredients list that would have thrown
me off but then again i probably wasn't
baking unless i was a baker let's just
move on and once our milk gets to about
body temperature we'll be adding our
yeast and our sugar but for now
let's just talk how are you good good
i'll holler when it's ready so you can
just go ahead and like browse do some
online chopping and i'll be like come
back
our milk is warm 21st century man we can
do 10 things at once and none of them
well
okay our milk is now warm enough come
back
adding some yeast
and a half teaspoon of sugar
great now we wait for the yeast to
activate
awesome now that our milk has this nice
like lightly foamy lightly aerated
texture we know our yeast is active and
ready to rock next we'll be taking 15
grams of butter and
grams of flour now we're gonna mix it
together into little pea sized chunks
but not too well mixed because remember
a big part of this is making sure that
our butter doesn't get too warm have you
guys ever tried baking it's hard i'm
gonna add just a little more butter last
but not least adding our milk
and we combine even with our leavened
dough you can already see that the
structure of it is already creating
layers and flaking
okay we're almost done kneading try and
get the last of it
waste not what not or as the french say
cool now that we have our levin dough
we're gonna set it aside and let it
proof
on to the next one
[Music]
our second dough is flour
a quarter
a quarter
do you need to take a minute co-stars a
quarter pound of freshly churned butter
and a grain of salt the recipe literally
says
a grain of salt
and a little milk
[Music]
that seems good now we're going to make
a fountain which basically means to put
a well in the center of our dough voila
the next step in the recipe says to
simply soak the dough i don't know what
that means so i'm going to guess that it
means add the remaining milk so we've
made one dough we've made our second
dough now it's time to combine our
doughs and then hopefully never make
dough again croissants to me seem like a
very high maintenance baked good i've
confirmed that fact so our two doughs
are now combined time to set it aside to
proof
[Music]
the next step is to break off
walnut-sized pieces and roll them into a
little ball be careful though because
the dough is so buttery you don't want
to spend too long rolling it with your
hands because you're actually warming it
up and that's going to melt the butter
and really just your croissant we're
gonna roll it out into an oval shape
ah nice
clingy stretchy rolly whoopsies okay
that's good the folding of the crescent
is probably the most important part of
this whole thing pin it with the left
hand then taking the right hand
roll it from the opposite end towards
the left
don't let your left hand help this is
something your right hand has to learn
to do on its own then we pinch it out a
little bit and fold it over the top
now we bend it into a vaguely crescent
shape
and then taking both hands
gently place it on our baking sheet so
now i've picked six to set aside and
we're just gonna sit back and let them
rise man there's a whole lot of waiting
in making a croissant
[Music]
now that they've risen our final step
before baking is to top them with a
light brushing of water we did this
because the water on the surface of the
croissants will create a sort of steam
once it enters the oven that'll help
with the leavening effect hi i'm hannah
i know what i'm talking about while the
croissants are baking our next step is
to make a light syrup this syrup is made
of cornstarch and water and that's it
okay judging from the amount of steam
oh yeah there we go
we'll just set that aside and then
finish up our croissants
hello
look at our croissants
now these don't look like modern day
croissants and we knew that but i also
didn't expect them
to just not at all resemble modern day
croissants maybe when they're shiny
it'll be more familiar
okay we take our starchy syrup which
has the texture and smell of a hot glue
and we give them a nice spread
now it's great because it looks like
somebody sneezed on them
so
here are our 19th century croissants
let's take a taste
[Music]
huh
it's a lot more like a thick
thick cracker i wouldn't call it a
biscuit
because biscuits have flavor let me just
taste this starch stuff
it tastes exactly like it looks i asked
jim whether or not people ate croissants
with something like butter or jam or ham
and cheese he said no which i find
surprising
[Music]
now from our modern day perspective this
may be pretty uninspiring but remember
this was the height of baking i can
understand why this was a beloved baked
good of the past i prefer what we have
in the present but it's pretty cool to
hold something that people haven't made
in over a hundred years cool
i had a lot of starch on it
[Music]
you